uh we have a really crazy situation
in the united states where because of
the mishandling of coronavirus by the
president
americans are trapped in the united
states
now this applies to healthcare
as many of you probably know it's common
that americans will go to canada for
insulin where it can be obtained much
less expensively
it's common that americans along the
southern border
will go to mexico for eye and dental
care i've shown these maps before but if
you look for example
at the mexican town small city
of los algodones you see that
it is just filled with eye and dental
clinics
why is this it's because americans cross
the border
to get high quality affordable eye and
dental care
except that now because of coronavirus
americans are allowed almost nowhere
around the world we have a health care
system that is such a fiasco
that regularly people will escape the
united states for medical treatment well
now they can't
in addition to just medical treatment
many people leave the united states for
education to go someplace where
college is less expensive that's
increasingly difficult to do
now with coronavirus i have friends who
have figured it out who for example
they want to be in europe to get away
from what's going on europe is not
most countries are not allowing
americans in so they go to the uk
where you can quarantine for 14 days if
coming from the u.s then you're in
and you can travel to other european
countries
but this is really a major issue more
than two million americans regularly buy
prescriptions abroad
that's mostly canada and mexico and
somehow
our horrible health care system has been
made even worse
by restricting the ability of americans
to essentially
flee to other countries with more
affordable health care and you still
have people
who don't recognize that we need
dramatic and drastic systemic change to
the american health care system now
if you want to go beyond medical we've
become the world pariah
we were the laughingstock we now
are the pity of the world and people are
also
angry at the irresponsibility of what's
going on in the united states
and you know i mentioned a few weeks ago
it has occurred to me
to just get out of the u.s in the fall
for what will likely be a very difficult
public health situation
and part of the reason that has held me
back from confirming those plans
is i am not that interested in being
seen
in other parts of the world as the
irresponsible americans
who were just traveling around and
potentially spreading coronavirus
obviously i would be careful i would
wear a mask i would get a test
i would quarantine i would do all of
that stuff but but i don't want to be
seen that way so donald trump's cult has
gotten what they wanted
they've essentially gotten close borders
we've closed many of our borders from
people coming in although that's
starting to loosen because
let's be honest the problem is
increasingly here not in other countries
and the united states is now on a
blacklist
in most parts of the world it's only
taken 187
000 dead in order to get those borders
closed so that americans
increasingly can't leave the united
states uh now just as a reminder on
health care
back in july donald trump told chris
wallace during that interview
within two weeks we'll sign a new health
care plan
into law never happened then trump said
it would be done by the end of august
well that's today it's not going to
happen every single day
trump should be pressed on that uh
because it is yet another one of those
failed
broken promises unfortunately and this
really is horrible for us and i know
you know people write to me from all
over the world who who watch the program
and they feel bad mostly
the us is feeling more and more like
gilead the uh uh
world described by margaret atwood
in her two novels handmaid's tale and
more recently the sequel
testaments it's very bad it is very very
bad
americans trapped in the united states